David we just saw a remnant from the
ashes and want to talk a little bit
about similarities between this and
blood-borne so remnant from the ashes is
a survival action game feels heavily
inspired by other games of late it takes
place in small chunks so basically it's
a game where you have a hub world with a
crystal that's kind of like a Stargate
you go through that Stargate into other
biomes we started with two biomes in
this 50-minute demo and then those
biomes randomly generate levels and
those levels randomly generate where the
enemies are placed in those levels and
you run through them every twenty to
thirty minutes and get on that loop
grind to get your character more
powerful yeah it's really interesting
that you mentioned that because you can
make so many direct comparisons to some
of the souls born games the safe points
for example you go to these areas where
you pretty much rest in all the minions
that you might have killed up until that
point will respawn you have limited
health that will also respond whenever
you use the rest points the sort of
aesthetic really kind of looks the same
too you have this third-person sort of
over the shoulder shooting fusion that
would kind of combine the souls bond
games would say like Resident Evil and
it does seem like a game that will offer
you kind of a hardy challenge without
being overly difficult which is kind of
a hot topic these days how difficult can
a game be before it becomes practically
unplayable or unlikable and on that note
this game is co-op it's one two three
players which actually does make the
game a bit more accessible and you're
right the difficulty level it's not
quite as sky-high as in the other games
however you are expected to die a couple
times figuring out boss patterns so it's
that tough but fair feeling the enemies
in this game do Telegraph their moves
pretty well with audio cues they have
pretty strong tells there's a lot of
ways for you to learn what they're about
to do and then avoid it or you know get
around it and figure out how to kill
them and doing that with other people
even though you have very limited
amounts of Health and you have to heal
yourself with these things called dragon
hearts but you only get back at those
save points so it does seem like these
elements and traits kind of make it a
Souls borne game but only in spirit
rather than scope because you have these
bite-sized dungeons that might only take
you say 20 to 30 minute chunks and that
kind of you can make those comparisons
with other games like destiny or the
division that kind of want to swamp all
of your time investing into its game
whereas with this you can it kind of
fits your style a little bit better it
kind of fits your schedule
we'll be better yeah it feels like you
can just hop in each night and knock out
one or two dungeons the game does appear
to have a lot of loot and that loot is
random for example in the first level I
dropped a sniper rifle and the developer
turned to me is like I've never seen
that drop this early before I like can
you shoot somebody and see how much
damage it does so we went off and I was
experimenting with the developer on this
weapon because they were genuinely
surprised that's a good sign like I
liked the idea of a game that just has a
large loot pool which has also been an
issue of late with game like anthem and
then just let you have a good crack at
that loot pool every night until you you
know you feel like you've had enough
this game also on top of that has a
fairly loose campaign which is kind of
cool but because of the randomly
generated levels two people will never
have the same experience entirely and
people can come out of the campaign with
completely different sets of loot as
other people your power in this game is
also just completely based on the loot
that you have there's no character level
or anything like that that should be
interesting it could also have some
unintended consequences such as if the
weapon does emerge as more powerful than
other weapons in this game there's no
particular way to grind for weapons the
developer said you actually might never
see the same boss as your friend who got
that awesome weapon from that one drop
so there are starting archetypes that's
the scrapper the Aeschylus and the
hunter they determine your range when
you start the game and then after that
it's just completely up to you there's
no limits to what your loadout is
there's also apparently a lot of Secrets
in this game of secret areas and secret
weapons we saw a couple which again I
can't tell you about you can go find
these early on in the game and it seems
like the kind of thing in a Souls born
game where you might activate something
early on and not know what it does until
later overall it just seems like there's
a ton of variety in this game with all
the random elements and then the game is
launching with over 100 enemies it's got
20 bosses
it's got regular bosses with random
elements to their fights and then it has
these world bosses who are much tougher
but also will drop some pretty
high-level loot so again like I think
this game at the end of the day is just
really good for people who like the
souls Bourne series but just don't have
a ton of time in their life for these
games not to say that you couldn't put a
lot of time into this game but this game
is probably best in small chunks for
sure and even if you're not a die-hard
Souls Bourne fan it does seem like this
could be a fairly more accessible game
for those who kind of want that
aesthetic who kind of enjoy games like
resident evil or shooter looter games
but they might just not have that much
time to invest in these types of games
remnant from the ashes comes out August
20th on PC ps4 and Xbox one for around
$40
[Music]